Can there be lightning with no rain or thunder?
Ah, the good old days, when lightning was nothing more than Zeus meting out judgment...
...in the form of deadly bolts hurled from atop Mount Olympus.
Fortunately, the advent of modern science allows us to understand and appreciate lightning...
...without all those messy animal sacrifices.
As droplets of moisture move within a cloud, they collide with one another.
This builds up negative charges at the cloud's base which repels electrons on the ground below.
So the earth beneath the cloud takes on an opposing positive charge.
And since opposites attract, a spark jumps between the positive and negative charges.
This spark can heat the air to more than 10,000 degrees Celsius.
That's hotter than the surface of the sun.
This superheated air expands rapidly resulting in a sound wave we call thunder,...
...which like a tree falling in the woods when no one is around,...
...still makes a sound despite what your philosophy teacher says.
Thunder usually only travels 16 to 24 kilometers.
But lightning can be seen for up to 160 kilometers.
You can see lightning and not hear thunder,...
...but that just means you are too far away to hear it, not that the thunder is absent.
A layer of warm air between the clouds and the ground...
...will sometimes evaporate the rain before it can fall.
This is called a dry thunderstorm, a common cause of wildfires.
So you can most definitely see lightning even when it isn't raining.
But we still don't recommend golfing on those days.
Zeus hates golfers.